mesdames et messieurs bonsoir 135 mille
foyers sont bons toujours en champagne
ardenne ce soir et électricité c'est
l'une des principales conséquences de la
tempête qui a balayé la région dans la
journée d'hier
depuis maintenant trente six heures des
dizaines de milliers d'habitants vivent
sans lumière et parfois sans chauffage à
l'image vous allez voir des
pensionnaires de cette maison de
retraite dans la marne ah ah voilà que
les troqueurs peu les pensionnaires de
la maison de retraite sont privés
d'électricité
3 peur transfo page sans eau chaude sans
ascenseur sans lumière on y trouve des
pieds à la tête
il s'agit de tenir le coup pour le
personnel ou les personnels qui servent
aux le repas sont obligés de tout faire
par sky et sa fille prennent leur
chariot il les envoie une bouche comme
cette lettre le font les affaires mais
la femme les soins ont c'est difficile
aussi parce qu'on n'avait pas deux
chaudes très peu donc fait ça faisait
longtemps
et puis le miracle la préfecture vient
de faire livrer un groupe électrogène à
l'électricien est réquisitionnée pour
installer provisoirement du chauffage
c'est la priorité j'aime faire l'examen
de puissance qui a besoin est pour
l'instant le meilleur solution à prendre
dans l'immédiat c'est d'alimenter la
chaufferie je vais la mesurer et si on
tombe sur une mesure contre un montant
tout sauf pour les soixante neuf
pensionnaires l'arrivée du chauffage est
accueilli comme une excellente nouvelle
même si le groupe électrogène est
insuffisant pour alimenter tout le
bâtiment
c'est pas grave la télé il la
regarderont plus tard mais le chauffage
arrive